في لحظه معينه اثرت بكثيرا عند قراءه
الروايه هي قصه الرجل الكبير السن الذي
اعدم ثلاثه من ابنائه بمعرفته وهو معه
معهم في داخل السجن وفي اللحظه التي كانوا
يعدمون فيها وكان يعني
ينتحب كان يبكي كان متاثرا بشده كانت اكثر
اللحظات صراحه التي اثرت في شخصيا
بكل الناس يعني
واسم القاضي يعني ليس حكم على يعني هو
حوالي يفدي واحد من ولاده اللي هو اخر
ولاده يعني قال له اعدلنا جميعا ولكن
اخيرا
او في البدايه وافقوا يعني ما حدا بيعرفه
من ابنائه 65 70 سنه وعدم
كان الرجل كبير السن يريد ان يبقي على
الصغير كي يتزوج لان الاخرين
يعني ما
خلفوا ومن خلف ما مات
فبده ابنه صغير كمان مشان لا ينقطع ذكره
بده يطلع على الحياه مره ثانيه ويجوز مره
ثانيه ويخلف
لانه الخلاف هاي القصه كانت كثير مؤثره
داخل السجن يعني هذا صحيح جدا صحيح جدا
داخل السجن وخارجه وستعيش بحكم سطوري
روايتك يعني دائما ان شاء الله لكي تحيي
هذه الوقائع المريره والماساويه التي
عايشتها مع الكثير الكثير من المعتقلين